[Musique]
alors sur ces belles images des grandes
villes canadiennes c'est l'équipe de tan
tan canada qui vous accueille à cette
édition du 12 avril
on n'est pas loin de pâques on approche
à grands pas et comme vous voyez la
température de l'eau c'est beau sur la
caméra c'est toujours beau mehdorn
montréal c'est un pull gris en ce moment
un très grise il est difficile de
tam-tam canada alors on accueille cette
semaine autour de la table de la table
géante qui peut accueillir jusqu'à 70
personnes aujourd'hui seulement 4
marie-claude aussi ma moto et puis notre
jeu favori de la section française
[Rires]
et puis et c'est notre copine demi
question vous braque une banque et un
quatrième dans alice kilométrique alice
chantal chandelle comme dans ok d'un
coup s'il y avait une tradition
oui moment donné ou encore qu'un dans
l'est dans les batailles mais on avait
tout nous suivre partage aux lego mari
pour les filles belle époque une chose
que c'est sûr on regarde la vidéo numéro
un parce que c'est là où se trouve le
secret des missions c'est le thème que
vous devez deviner mais mme marie-claude
notre webmestre du côté français ne sait
pas de quoi il s'agit même si elle a
parlé aux invités aujourd'hui qu'ils
vont être sur skype on regarde ces
images numéro un
vous criez dès que vous avez
l'impression d'être sur une piste
quelque chose à voir mais personne et
d'un fort d'un an de nord de toronto
vous êtes la dr who we le sujet ça oui
très bon deux points à 2 mètres de haut
ou un sobre et puis ensuite médecins
ambulances
gensse gens soient tout à faire et ils
ont des pancartes dans l'est mais oui
pour c'est dans cette voie là pour un
canton plus grand contrôle des armes à
feu deux villes voilà écoutez c'est un
gros sujet ce qu'on traîne un boulet où
l'opinion voit là mais là il ya eu du
nouveau parce que il ya eu une offensive
médiatique de la part des médecins en
urgence au canada les différentes villes
qui est dans les grandes villes jour il
y en avait mais beaucoup beaucoup ont
participé un article là dessus
oui tout à fait c'est des médecins qui
sont mobilisés pour dénoncer l' usage
abusif des armes à feu quitterait pas
mal de problèmes dans l'eau saine de la
population pas s'il ya des blessés
graves qui s'amène dans les urgences est
vraiment les médecins sont débordés ils
ont tenu à dire leur ras-le-bol par
rapport à ce phénomène là ils ont
surtout interpeller les responsables
politiques à légiférer sur la question
il ya un projet d'un projet de loi qui a
été déposé
fait longtemps il ya des lobby derrière
qui tire les ficelles donc après sa
fille dans un registre qui a été éliminé
par les conservateurs au pouvoir
c'est compliqué ces histoires nous on va
essayer de montrer le débat actuel avec
la nouvelle loi
ce que disent les médecins qui sont pas
des spécialistes des armatures jeudi
gspc des armes à feu pour se défendre
et puis être absents on va essayer
d'avoir un débat sur skype d'abord je
vous présente ce reportage de philippe
leblanc juste pour une mise en scène de
ce que disent les médecins peau parce
que c'est eux qui traitent le problème
ou aux urgences on organise a viré au
numéro 2
m la plupart des médecins porter leur
sarraut traiter les victimes fait partie
de leur quotidien à toronto où l'on
dénombre déjà 78 fusillade cette année
on parle d'une augmentation de 40 % en
cinq ans au pays il ya deux semaines
pendant une semaine j'ai eu trois
blessés par balles
et puis à tous ont été blessées pays qui
ont une réglementation plus sévère
ben ça fonctionne les incidents avec les
armes à feu sa baisse
les médecins demandent au gouvernement
trudeau d'adopter le projet de loi c 71
visant à encadrer la commercialisation
et la possession d'armes à feu
le projet de loi déposé il ya un an est
à l'étude ou cela
bien sûr à cette émission en plus de
s'informer on s'amuse ce normal par le
jeu souvent par nécessité un outil façon
de faire progresser les la conversation
entre nous tous entre nos gens qui sont
de l'autre côté et ceux qui sont ici en
studio puis des fois la régie se mêle à
la partie pouvoir qui répond bien à nos
trois questions à chaque émission
composent
il ya s'enroule à perdre vous secouez
vous savez c'est quoi la chanson c'est
un sas et de règlements paloma de
talents de manager exactement la section
espagnole t1 et vente et ça c'est pas
moi alors 20 boules à perdre pour ce
premier jeu on va afficher à l'écran
choix c'est une nouveauté qu'on vous
propose cette semaine c'est la régie
encore une fois qui veut exceller
alors il faut bien je n'ai pas regardé
ça c'est là donc premier tour de la
grosse boule on voit si la question
d'abord un type brillant bull depuis
2013 de nombre de victimes de crimes
violents liés aux armes à feu à bord
dans la quasi totalité du pays dites moi
en 2013 et 2016 loto de crimes violents
liés aux armes à feu est en hausse de
quel pourcentage selon vous etes à 44% b
33 % ou ses 22 % moi je dirais c'est 22%
marie-claude 10 et 22 pouces très bien
raymond de la côte est je dirai la même
chose même deux pour ça et bien vous
allez suivre le bal non j'ai pas dit
suivre la balle mais alors qui vise
juste
l'offre est pas d'autre je ne
mentionnerai pas où aller alors la bonne
réponse c'est écouter on va demander à
notre premier invité aujourd'hui de
déterminer la bonne réponse
il s'agit tout simplement de quelqu'un
qui s'y connaît très bien c'est un
spécialiste de la question des armes à
feu au pays francis m'envoie professeur
d'histoire au cégep de trois-rivières
monsieur l'envoi bonjour bonjour alors
vous avez entendu comme les autres la
question quelle est la bonne réponse 43%
33% 22% entre 2013 et 2016 le tour de
crimes violents liés aux armes à feu est
en hausse de quel pourcentage vous
avouer que je peux regarder si
schaeffler mais j'ai l'impression c'est
autour de 44%
aulas ouais en fait c'est 44%
justement ça va lui viser juste alors
donnez moi moi c'est un automatisme en
journalisme rapidement on vous a vu de
l'émission parce que vous avez accordé
des entrevues pour essayer d'expliquer
certaines lacunes dans les lois
actuelles au canada sur les armes à feu
qui font en sorte que peut-être on
n'était pas aussi en aussi grande
sécurité qu'on le pende si on se compare
par exemple aux états unis et ce modèle
américain que tout le monde a en tête
évidemment ça c'est assez facile à
décrire mais quelle est la situation au
canada au niveau des armes à feu est ce
que par exemple si j'ai un problème je
suis je suis dépressif on voit ça
souvent des gens qui sont des prêts
s'est fait qu'ils veulent accomplir des
actes tout à fait répréhensible
est ce que s'est passé au canada est-ce
que c'est quelles sont les limites de
l'action d'une personne pour se procurer
une arme à feu en ce moment donc pour se
procurer une arme à feu les personnes
doivent obtenir un permis de possession
et donc c'est ce qui me lui permit de
son acheter une ceci étant dit les armes
au canada sont catégorisées de quoi trop
différentes catégories voilà donc les
hommes qui sont prohibés donc interdite
des armes qui sont non à autorisation
restreinte pendant donc ces armes là
sont les essentiellement les armes de
poing et certains modèles de fusils
d'assaut qui sont motivés pour être
accessible civile et donc des armées qui
sont à autorisation non restreint donc
essentiellement toutes les armes de
chasse les armes longues donc calé chat
selon qu'on se procurer ceci étant dit
la classification des armes c'était
beaucoup ici au canada en fonction de la
longueur du cadeau ce qui fait que
certains modèles ont de diversion stv2
de fusils d'assaut se retrouve dans la
catégorie non non restreint et ce sont
des armes sont relativement faciles à
obtenir
donc tout ce que ça prend donc c'est un
retour sur les antécédents judiciaires
et psychiatriques pour obtenir sa est
essentiellement ce qu'on fait lorsque
l'on regarde la personne pourrait
obtenir une arme vers dans le formulaire
ou demande si la personne a eu des
problèmes psychiatriques auparavant
alors à moins que la personne soit fiché
ben il faut ski à la bonne foi des gens
et ça a eu bon garder intact c'est dans
ces terribles donc son temps ce qui
permet la mosquée québec la personne qui
avait ces armes-là avait coché qu'elle
n'avait pas d'antécédents psychiatriques
alors qu'elle était dépressive et sous
médication donc la loi est à modifier
vous hantera renforcée à ce niveau là
vous me demandez si une personne qui a
des problèmes de santé mentale pour
obtenir une arme
en théorie non mais en pratique mines
quelle est la situation à toronto
une grande partie de la raison pour
laquelle j'ai décidé de nice ce sujet à
l'édition aujourd'hui c'est en fonction
des préoccupations de la ville de
toronto a aussi à edmonton winnipeg ce
sont des villes où le taux de fusillade
est plus élevé que par exemple à
montréal montreal un peu l'impression
qu'on vit dans un petit on est entouré
c'est pas comme à toronto où on a vécu
l'an dernier je sais pas combien de
dizaines de fusillade entre des gagnants
mais généralement c'est tout à fait on
disait qu'on a deux canadairs deux
réalités
quelle est la situation au niveau des
armes à feu à toronto précisément dans
l'ensemble des villes des grandes villes
canadiennes
il ya une augmentation des homicides et
des blessures par arme à feu
c'est une tendance générale depuis
quelques années mais sur ces classes
maintenant à toronto visiblement il ya
une
quand je crée une situation qui est
assez particulière dans la mesure où il
y aura sûrement à quelque part garde de
gagne ou un problème lié avec les crimes
organisés qui fait que premièrement il
ya des affrontements qui se déroulent
deuxièmement donc il ya accessibilité
aux armateurs qui est plus grande
probablement puisque la ville est plus
grande mais aussi parce que la ville est
relativement proche c'est un immense
nous le disons commerciales entre les
etats-unis et le canada est donc
probablement que il ya aussi un trafic
disons assez élevé certains pointent
donc des armes à feu en provenance de la
frontière
ceci étant dit la police de toronto avec
des études qui sont pour l'instant assez
préliminaire a démontré qu'il est légère
c'est aussi le phénomène s'observe
également en train de retenir donc dix
dernières années tendent à montrer que
le nombre d'armes à feu sont en
provenance du canada dont qui ont été
obtenus de façon légale ou illégale en
provenance du canada sur les scènes de
crime tu argumentes et donc probablement
il est difficile d'établir des
corrélations direct mais probablement
parce qu'il y a lieu au desserrement du
contrôle des armes à tulle par le
gouvernement de stephen harper durant
les années 2002 qu une chose est sûre
pour l'instant on semble voir le kef une
augmentation du nombre d'armes à feu en
circulation est particulièrement de en
provenance du canada donc ce que je
disais sur les scènes de crime le final
est tellement fort qui en colombie
britannique
on est mise sur place en 2010 est une
des spéciales pour étudier justement
l'élu les leaks choisir les quatre
tonnes de trafic d'armes arthur à
l'intérieur de la province
donc ça vous donne une dit le deal de
l'emploi on va revenir sur le projet de
loi c 71
on sait que ben on a entendu tous le cri
du coeur des médecins qui souhaitent un
resserrement de la loi en ce qui
concerne le contrôle des armes de poing
et des armes d'assaut
on sait qu'au niveau du projet de loi
ses 71 l'accent est mis davantage sur le
contrôle des antécédents judiciaires
hier deux personnes qui souhaitent
acheter ou acquérir ce type d'armes
quelles réflexions vous suggère
l'attitude des politiques par rapport à
ce projet de loi là je pense que le
gouvernement libéral en ce moment tente
de ménager la chine riche ou dans la
mesure où le projet de loi est claire
oui ça augmente le contrôle sur certains
points donc on veut remonter plus loin
dans les dents les antécédents des
personnes qui veulent obtenir des
armatures donc pour l'instant c'est on
remonte jusqu'à 5 en arrière mais où
voulait retourner jusque bref dans
l'ensemble de la personne on essaie de
personnes vous voyez les conservateurs
essaient de bloquer cet aspect de la loi
envers au ski bosses faire
donc oui l'autre chose qu'on connaissait
deux faces de forcer les détaillants
d'armes donc à maintenir un inventaire
de toutes les armes à feu qui possède
donc un magasin de toutes les
transactions qui font ce qui est
prophète en ce moment et aussi on veut
forcer les comme je faisais tout les
gens qui font une transaction et piquant
est normal qu a demandé une vérification
des antécédents de la personne et donc
la validité de son permis
lors d'une transaction donc que ce soit
en magasin ou entre des particuliers
donc c'est ce qu'ont ce qu'on espère
faire maintenant je pense que le d'écran
problèmes qu'on voie ce qui a des armes
est extrêmement performante efficaces
qui sont en circulation au canada de
façon légale ou illégale mais une chose
est sûre des armes achetées légalement
peuvent se retrouver entre de mauvaises
mains et des pistolets ou encore des
armes d'assaut même des versions civiles
d'armes d'assaut ça donne une puissance
de feu incroyable n'importe quel
individu
donc ce qui permet et on le voit au sud
appréciable on le voit ici au canada
donc là lily tueries qui ont eu lieu
dans les lieux publics que ce soit des
écoles des lieux de culte c'est donc ont
été menées essentiellement par des gens
qui avaient des armes aux capacités donc
déçoit des fusils d'assaut ou encore
dexter est donc larmes en tant que tel
devient facilitateur permet à un
individu de commettre des crimes sont
énormes
et je pense que le gouvernement était
bien de se poser la question est ce
qu'on va falloir rebondir augmenter la
réglementation concernant les fusils
d'assaut les armes de poing et jeu à mon
avis son ciel d'autres exemples dans
d'autres pays que je pense à
l'angleterre à l'australie par exemple
où un cas extrême au japon parce qu'ils
avaient littéralement pas d'armes à feu
des de contrôler ces armes là bas ça
permet de diminuer le risque ce nom de
l'éliminer presqu'au complet tant que
jack ont donc de diminuer le risque y
ait des tueries de masse puis donc peu
d'écrits de ce type lecture commis au
canada
beaucoup de questions autour de la terre
au four à bois reymond oui ben vous
parler du japon où les liens qu
intéressant aussi qui est à observer qui
tout récent celui de nouvelle-zélande
mais on est jeune mais on est dans un
espace clos ces deux longs partout
alentour
nous on a cette longue frontière et on a
aussi historiquement parce que vous êtes
professeur d'histoire également toute
cette notion de la liberté de l'individu
dû gérer poche coureurs de bois mais de
larmes comme outil essentiel essentiel
de protection de soi et aussi de
prolonger one soit vous arrivez à ce
moment là dans un espace où c'est le
propriétaire dame trop souvent va se
dire bon vu pourquoi on vient talonner
mon espace privé et ça c'est un
changement de paradigme majeur qui se
doit d'être présenté et avec les lobbies
par exemple et narry c'est très
difficile à fall vous avez raison les
toutes les tentatives de réglementation
des armes à feu par celle de monsieur
chrétien 1995
wall a été extrêmement difficile leveaux
américain évidemment change complètement
la donne étant donné la quantité
phénoménale d'armes à feu sont en
circulation ce des frontières vous avez
raison la conseillère relativement
poreuse ya des réseaux très bien établie
donc qui qui traversent des armes de sud
vers le nord
effectivement ce sont des données dont
il faut tenir compte si on veut
réglementer interdire terol et certains
types d'armes vous avez absolument
raison
ceci étant dit la disponibilité et une
corrélation nette entre la disponibilité
des armes
eux se rater trois données et leur
utilisation dans la mesure où est ce que
si elles sont là il ya plus de chances
que ce soit ben ali auquel seraient sur
trois en de mauvaises mains donc un
moyen de diminuer mais non pas
d'éliminer effectivement tous les deux
les risques associés aux armes à feu
pour ce qui est de la question de la
propriété privée vous avez raison ces
armes là ont été acquises légalement et
donc si le gouvernement
admettons advenant le coeur qu'il fasse
il faudrait qu'il fasse comme en
australie ou en angleterre donc est un
programme de rachat de ses armes le
premier était absolument on peut pas
saisir des objets comme ce sens que ce
soit bien fait donc c'est cela la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que ici au canada au monde oui vous avez
raison le bon le courant des bois le
pionnier qui arrive avec sa carabine
mais effectivement il ya une longue
histoire de gens qui sont armés mais
c'est rien pour aller premièrement de
ski au sud de la frontière
et l'autre chose c'est que la cour
suprême plusieurs reprises au cours du
20e siècle place clairement dans les
dernières décennies blacks ont supprimé
la couronne et certaines provinces comme
en saskatchewan par exemple à traîner
statué que de posséder normes arthur est
un privilège et non pas un droit garanti
par la constitution comme celui aux
états unis et donc le gouvernement a le
droit de légiférer de limiter d'encadrer
la possession l'utilisation de ces
objets là et ces objets qui rappelons le
sont des objets qui sont faits poursuit
essentiellement que ce soir-là êtres
humains ou encore des ennemis mais il
reste que ce sont des objets achetés
comment je peux dire dangereux donc
s'ils sont réglementées voitures sont
réglementées permis de chasse sur
règlement des permis de pêche
aujourd'hui je vois pas pourquoi on
prépare réglementé resserrer le contrôle
des objets l'eau marie-claude écouter
j'aurai beaucoup de questions il y avoue
vieux différend vrai j'ai ces
différentes classifications d'art maison
que je vais y aller avec une question
simple qu'est-ce qu'une arme d'assaut
puis c'est ce que je sais c'est qu'une
arme d'assaut n'est pas légale des mails
et sequalum d'assaut ça sera quoi la
version légale
certainement donc les armes d'assaut
sont des fusils d'assaut donc qui sont
utilisées par les armées
tous ont des armes qui tire un calibre
moyen pas trop gros pour trop petit
parce qu'on veut quelque chose
d'efficace mais pas trop lourd à
transporter on veut beaucoup de balles
ce sont des armes qui se tiennent
généralement d'humains qui sont qu'ils
ont avec lesquels on peut tirer de façon
semi automatique ou automatique des
armes qui ont des chargeurs détachable
des armes donc on peut donc on peut
utiliser beaucoup de balles et recharger
la remet rapidement des armes qui ont
une poignée pistolet dont contient qui
commence cody qui est une protubérance
qui sort du mécanisme retire donc une
carabine
le mécanisme de tels différends dont
contient la crosse de la remorque un
fusil d'assaut généralement il y une
poignée indépendante facilite
l'utilisation de l'armée le tir et
d'armes automatiques et les en dessous
dernièrement aussi donc possède comme je
peux dire des déserts des emplacements
sur le leur montrer où on peut installer
des des mécanismes qui permettent de
faciliter le tri que ce soit des
meilleurs des lampes de poche des
baïonnettes des lance-grenades ont été
dans les airs par exemple il en alla
voir effectivement absolument et donc on
peut obtenir des baisses sur des
versions civiles de ces armes laisse au
canada c'est légal les versions civiles
donc ne peuvent que tirer de façon semi
automatique et les chargeant en théorie
au canada sont limitées à cinq balles
alors que les chargeurs explique de
l'armée canadienne par exemple
américaine donc ce sont des changeurs de
trondheim donc en avoir 50 jusqu'à 100
balles ou suivent donc souci par contre
c'est s'échangeant le sont disponibles
sur le marché canadien mais en théorie
sont limitées à cinq balles donc les
prises d'assaut dont je parle
les versions civiles semi automatiques
sont légales donc on en a vu beaucoup de
mal quiconque aime ce genre de chose de
pu s'en procurer un c'est sûr que
certains contrôles évidemment quand elle
fois à suivre certaines sont
catégorisées comme tribe et d'autres
sont catégorisées comme l'autorisation
restreint et certaines en fait une large
part de celle-ci donc vous avez le
mécanisme de téléchargeurs détachable la
poignée dépendante des endroits pour
installer des diviseurs des choses comme
ça l'inde grande partie de ces armes à
leur sont considérés parce que le canon
est assez longs comme des armes de
chasse donc sont assez accessible
comprenez que de modifier un chargeur
qui limitait à cinq balles c'est très
facile parce que l'essentiel des
modifications qui limite le nombre de
balles qu'on peut mettre dans le
chargeur et anciennement une vi on met
dans le chargeur donc on a simplement
retiré la ville on peut se retrouver
avec un chargeur de 30 balles ou 200
balles donc pour ce qu'il est changeant
le tronc de balle bale lors de
l'attentât complet marois au métropolis
à montréal bell le tir à ravir la même
chose la mosquée de québec
il sait jamais d'armé avec des armes les
versions civiles de fusils d'assaut
oui effectivement semi automatique mais
qui tirait du cas les basses et puissant
et qu'il y avait une bonne puissance de
ce partouche ans dans les deux les armes
se sont régalés donc il faudrait re
classe qui donc les armes de façon plus
on rit six professeurs il faut se
quitter il va falloir laisser la parole
à l'autre point de vue parce qu'il ya
celui des chasseurs celui de ceux qui
possèdent des armes à feu on va voir ce
qu'ils en pensent de tout ça alors
francis langlois professeur d'histoire
au cégep de trois-rivières merci finit
pas d'être venu aujourd'hui à l'émission
merci des gens qui sont de haut calibre
exemple n'y avait pas de jus de moules
d'un cas ça c'était voulu ça n'aide du
coeur c'est important quand ça vient du
coeur alors on vous on va avoir un petit
jeu du jeu de la grosse boule vous avez
tous perdu 20 boules au premier jeu la
c30 et tout ça et là vous allez
peut-être rentrer l'on va perdre un peu
comme ça alors en attendant les vers
notre invité prochaine éviter voici la
question on va l'affiché la régie va
afficher sa prend pas de temps
d'ailleurs ça prend une seconde ou deux
pour que la régie à moi dakar alors
c'est le deuxième tour attendez que moi
jaffe la question ce matin le bizet
l'écrin havlat vais là où c'est vrai sur
la mort de la gare
quel pourcentage effectivement encore en
vie
qu'ils arrivent à l'hôpital vont finir
par décédées de leurs blessures chasse
une question que je me suis jamais posée
mais en la voyant l'autre jour c'était
écrit dans un document de médecins j'ai
dit waouh c'est quelque chose se poser
ce genre de question laquelle la réponse
maintenant est-ce que c'est à 20%
est ce que ce serait le b 40 % ou est-ce
que sur ces 80 % des gens qui arrivent à
l'hôpital qui ont reçu travail on arrive
à les sauver de combien de pourcentage
des cas ce que casser 20 40 ou 80 % que
de la bonne réponse c'est avant tout en
tant que journaliste quand on entend que
la victime elle s'est rendue à l'hôpital
il me semble qu'en général on a juste
mais on la personne en général on est
décédé peut-être donc seulement 20% des
gens et c'est une fois arrivé à
l'hôpital fait bien 40-40 pour ça vous
regarde et le juste milieu
une chaîne de télévision alternative pas
du tout la carotte aussi vous aussi vous
versiez vacances à 80 la bonne réponse
qu'y perdre en boule
malheureusement seulement 20%
bon ben coudon bonne nouvelle alors
d'aller vers notre seconde invitée il
s'agit de m guy lavergne de
l'association canadienne des armes à feu
m lavergne bonjour bonjour avez vous eu
l'occasion grâce aux nouvelles
technologies de entendre les propos du
professeur d'emplois sur facebook sur
notre plate forme alors qu'une diffusion
où vous avez raté cette première partie
d'entre vous je ne sais trop
j'ai raté la première partie parce que
je n'étais pas au courant que je devais
la largueur et n'apprécie pas ce terrain
tepa c'est ça on voulait vous mettre
tous les deux ensemble et techniquement
aujourd'hui skype ne voulait pas
accepter la commande ce sera peut être
réparé la semaine prochaine mais alors
par où des choses très simplement vous
lisez comme moi les journaux plein
d'affirmations sur les armes à feu il ya
des images qui circulent on sait de quoi
faire peur aux gens qu elles sont
prenez-en une de ces affirmations qui
n'a aucun sens et qui en a aucun
sens pour les gens qui possèdent des
armes à feu qui entend dire qu'on veut
maintenant réglementé encore plus leurs
objets eux je pense elle qui me plaît le
plus c'est la dernière liste à savoir
que bannir les armes de poing amènerait
une restitution des criminels
il laisse moi vous expliquer les raisons
pour lesquelles le l'accès aux armes de
poing et heather mac ou d'ailleurs est
déjà extrêmement contrôlées au canada le
principe de base dont des armes à feu au
canada c'est que la possession de toutes
armes à tous quelle qu'elle soit une
infraction criminelle au départ alors il
n'ya que des gens se sont vu remettre
par les policiers peuvent y avoir légal
max ce qui n'est pas le cas des
individus criminalisés oblige à toulouse
donc essentiellement venir l'accès aux
armes de poing pour les gens plutôt le
bannir législativement barattage déjà
n'affecterait fin pratique que les gens
qui sans cela mérite sportif et n'aurait
absolument aucun effet sur les gens qui
sont entretenus à des fins criminelles
parce que ces gens là une simple de se
les procurent pauvres par les canaux
légaux mais à des canaux de jouer dans
un thermos de ruelle du panais par des
canaux occultes qui échappent au
contrôle des autorités policières
d'après vous la meilleure façon de
procéder de fin du jeu veut dire de
resserrer ce contrôle la serait de je
sais pas moi d'accentuer le contrôle au
niveau des frontières pas ou rentrent
souvent les armes à feu ce serait une
excellente des lieux des instruments ou
est par exemple une personne a été
intercepté avec 25 armes de poing
si les deux
avoir d'essence de voiture c'était une
personne qui avait une carte nexus donc
ils y avaient été autorisés les
autorités douanières a traversé la
frontière à répétition sain pour drones
nous avancer et cette personne non il
n'est faite entre le calendrier de
chimie à haute fréquence peut s'imaginer
que le nombre d'armes de poing qui ont
été en afrique illégalement au canada à
cette personne est extrêmement bien
vraiment on doit que moi j'ai un confort
là dedans genoux vous dire si vous avez
mis le feu certains c'est un cas que
vous montez en exergue et c'est un fait
vous avez raison ce qu'aulas est un cas
pata est ce le cas systématique quand on
fait des lois
cardin gouvernement doit faire des lois
c'est pour le plus grand bénéfice
comme et non pas pour répondre à un
point x où j'ai un problème moi c'est
quand vous dites qu'une personne se
procure une arme de poing de façon
légale pour l'activité sportive et que
l'autre se le procurent illégalement
d'après se procurent illégalement une
arme c'est souvent fois une âme volé à
une personne qui sont les procurer
légalement
ensuite j'ai un problème moins
philosophique personnel c'est tout avec
le concept même d'utiliser les armes de
poing à des fins sportives je ne
comprends pas personnellement le plaisir
de la chose et je rêve pas aux mains
le premier qui a trait aux arts le volet
il y effectivement un prénom d'armes à
feu qui sont voilées de personnel je
vous signalerais par exemple eu la
personne et je le dis au sens large les
personnes disaient qui s'est fait voler
leurs armes à feu ces dernières années
au canada
c'est une organisation connue
le nom de gs ils nous arrêtent et
policières sont fréquemment victimes de
vols armés d'armes à feu dans l'édicule
et je pense que le chiffre les dernières
années de 296 armes dérobées à la js
deuxièmement je vois pas de l'esthétisme
encore une fois sur les armes à feu qui
ont été reclassés comme provenant de
voir l'effectif au canada également mon
exact if des criminels et ça représente
mais une partie du haut du nombre total
d'armes à feu qui ont été utilisés à des
fins criminelles
troisièmement comme si ce n'est une
partie si jamais ce sursaut nord à
savoir des envolées de baic est pris par
une prohibition totale de procession
mais ma vie pêche sportive
il est évident que ça n'affecte pas les
autres sources d'approvisionnement avec
un criminel et ce n'est tout simplement
avoir le même si l'image communiqué
votre deuxième point à savoir que vous
ne comprenez pas pourquoi on les utilise
à des fins sportives
je vous dirais que je les cobras rh de
génie à dom
c'est une activité qui peut être
agréable et les kinés et extrêmement
solitaire ne met pas en danger
ce soit je vous signale par hasard par
ailleurs je veux dire que plusieurs mois
les piques pas d'appel à des armes à feu
c'est évidemment à possède pour vous
montrer le délai mais il reste que ce
sont des sports légitime qu'ils ont leur
place au programme du jeu année avec
loeb
mais on avait un début d'émission une
statistique qui disaient que je pense de
2013 à 2016 y avait une augmentation de
crimes commis impliquant des armes à feu
doux pendant 10 à 44 cents donc selon
vous ce serait plus des armes car été
obtenus illégalement plutôt qu'avec des
hommes qui avaient été obtenues
légalement je pense que nous notre aux
spécialistes me semblait dire que c'est
un mélange des deux je vais premièrement
les nids 2013 qu'une anomalie
statistique
à savoir que c'était historiquement
l'année où le le plus petit nombre de
crimes par arme à feu
et jamais je vous signale par ailleurs
il indique que chili l'abolition du
régime d enlever leurs gîtes maisons des
courses au fédéral
je vous suggère pointé une part
élections au public je vous en fait
c'est le mal à vraiment prendre l'année
2011 comme année de référence n'ont
aucun sens parce que c'était une
anomalie statistique qui sen qui
s'inscrivent dans une tendance baissière
il apparemment s'était accélérée en 2014
et 2016
les statistiques mans sa porte parole si
on regarde la moyenne des amis en
question et qu'on regarde les
statistiques actuelles y aurait eu une
légère hausse
effectivement mais ce que vous voyez
c'est d'abord et avant on aurait une
recrudescence de la guerre began noémie
lupion toronto et ces gens là évidemment
sont incapables d'obtenir un permis
format court et je paie des policiers
nous ont reconnus comme étant des
membres de gangs de rue et lise lire
part il est qu ils m ont remis des
activités de trafic de drogues illégales
et de défense du peu de territoire pour
le trafic des drogues illégales
ce qui n'a absolument rien à voir avec
l'utilisation illégale des armes à feu
alipay sportives ou les disponibilités
des armes à feu avait fait sportive
encore
une fois muni d'un pont du leu l'objet
d'une approbation
alors il est facile de m camille mais
ils ont pris le relais merci d'avoir
apporté cette querelle à d'avoir ramassé
salah sûr c'est très bien j'aimerais ça
vous donner plus de temps
malheureusement je commence à manquer de
temps et je pense qu'on vous a donné
presque autant de temps que l'autre
invité donc j'ai le sentiment de devoir
à moitié bien accompli je remercie un
film à avoir accepté de participer
aujourd'hui nous aider à avoir l'autre
côté de l'information
souvent on y va on entend ouais mais
c'est moi qui vous remercie j'aime
absolument une dernière précision avant
que j'y joue sur votre nez que j'ai 86
un méta de l'association canadienne pour
les hommes le sait nous a signalé que
c'est un ami qui met partout que je ne
suis pas là miller je me suis mis leurs
représentants miller porte parole et mon
intervention se maintenait ici on est
très bien on va mettre ça dans toutes
les face à cette émission sera diffusée
en différé
merci beaucoup m d'avoir participé
aujourd'hui merci youtube heures alors
que c'était donc m guy lavergne
à titre personnel on a le temps pour
repas ne peuvent pas en valais pas et
joue et je suis tout de suite je voulais
vous amener sur notre site web
quand on parle de différer une fois que
notre émission en différé mais une fois
que notre émission est en reprise et les
diffusées en reprise après 11h15 après
sur l'heure du midi à peu près 12h15
alors de montréal il ya la page web de
tam tam qui apparaît et on vous présente
alors des pour ajouter un peu à la
conversation dont aux articles ont été
publiés sur cette question la règle
thématiques notamment votre article sur
les médecins sur les médecins qui ont
manifesté dans les grandes capitales
nationales
dire leur ras-le-bol par rapport à ce
phénomène la vidéo numéro 5 on regarde
ça ensemble à quoi ça ressemble cette
semaine et puis pendant qu'on regarde ça
on peut aussi mentionner qu'on peut
écouter donc la version audio de cette
émission pour ceux qui veulent faire ça
rapidement ou télécharger et baladeurs
tout ça dans ça c'est l'émission de la
semaine dernière vous donner un exemple
et puis toujours la semaine dernière
vous regardez en images allaient
rapidement mais je ne vais quitter à
notre question c'est parce que la
jeunesse algérienne
vous avez marre gaza allez voir ça sur
tintin canada de nos émissions sont en
reprise
voilà les thèmes cette semaine où les
pages web pour ajouter à la conversation
puis on assure un set cette semaine j'ai
des petits vieux moi je vois mal mais je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'informations
qu'il y aurait là encore m'a en fait un
bruit la question des éditions un point
de vue les pros et des contres très en
profondeur
excellent et on y retrouvait d'ailleurs
mais que maître guy lavergne
je voulais vous vous allez nous a menés
aux vidéos à présenter parce que c'est
votre plaisir personnel ça fasse vrai
que cette semaine dans l'émirat non mais
on a un réalisateur à radio-canada qui
nous a fait une petite vidéo pour
présenter notre application donc
pour ensuite incité les gens à
télécharger l'application radio canada
international sur leur téléphone c'est
tellement agréable de lire nos nouvelles
avec cette application quand vous voyez
à l'écran un peu visuellement de quoi ça
leur les nouvelles de radio-canada
international sont en cinq langues
français anglais espagnol arabe et
chinois vous choisissez les langues qui
vous intéressent
moi j'ai l'anglais de français qui sont
dans nous dit sur mon téléphone
et puis voilà vous allez si vous avez un
téléphone android vous allez sur google
créé ou téléphone alors on y va quand le
dernier jeu de la grosse boule combien
se voulait perdre aux 50 hertz est là
alors vous avez toujours 80 bull
ouais il vous en reste la moitié 50 50
même chose pour moi ou pas les plaindre
alors voici on affiche avec les doigts
ouais alors c'est très chaud c'est très
simple écoute et on va on regarde et les
etats unis comment ça se passe peut-être
pas dit qu'on va regarder le canada
parce que je vous ai induit en erreur
voici la question quelle ville détient
maintenant le titre de capitale
nord-américaine du match on a beaucoup
parlé de toronto c'est peut-être quelque
chose à considérer que c'est maintenant
la capitale nord-américaine du meurtre
alors est-ce que c'est à toronto
maintenant est ce que c b chicago est ce
que c'est des dallas wen a pas donné d
est ce que c'est hadas commerciaux pour
moi c'est louis qui vont être jaloux là
si on est tombé chicago pour la b
d'accord c'est la capitale
nord-américaine du meurtre d'un agent et
saint louis c'est chic c'est chicago
vous dites alors dites-moi qui qui
répondent qu'ils répondent qu'ils
répondent chicago et st louis
il ya deux bonnes réponses a perdu des
points tantôt révolter alors c'est parce
que la dernier chicago a enregistré 650
notre c'est pratiquement autant que dans
tout le canada
mais c'est toutefois c'est louis au
missouri qui remporte le titre
triste de capital du meurtre aux états
unis 180 millimètres met en relation
avec sa population en comparaison c'est
59000 aux minots pas 59-59 homicide par
cent mille habitants au canada pour
donner une idée là c'est en général 2 2%
dans le pire des cas à montréal je
pensais 1,1 14%
c'est au québec où les tos québec et les
maritimes où les taux sont les moyens
d'élever winnipeg alberta ou edmonton cd
v où il a fait les taux sont peut-être
plus élevé qu'à toronto
en ce moment les ouvriers étaient très
très violente également aux etats unis
c'est barthou mois ben oui pourtant
c'est une jolie ville oui mais oui mais
pas ok tu sors mieux où vivent ici au
canada je pense pour hambourg depuis la
triste et l'école on nous dit que le
canada est moins cher on est bien
informé
écoutez images la semelle il reste très
peu de minutes à cette émission avoir de
perte de satellites
comme vous le savez alors images la
semaine non répond pardon si ça avait
été moi que choisissait l'allumage à
semaine j'aurai choisi monsieur saint
jean l'astronaute canadien dans l'espace
c'est ça qui a marché dans l'espace est
[Musique]
basse et vous vous là moi je fus tous
tellement des images non c'est pas ça
mais sans réduction c'est pas l'algérie
non c'est pas le jerry l'algérie elle
était douce à fécamp me sélectionnant ça
répète au soudan je voudrais par ou par
non vraiment à dakar en amérique du nord
non en europe oui aux accès non leur
part du plach site normand non ça aurait
pu se résumer rap
arrestations et aux juniors à 100 pour
ceux qui ont arrêté l'arrestation le
matin la voix la demande ça compte
yahiaoui il en sortit un homme barbu
fatigué vous
j'avais dit par le faisceau c'est
l'image un peu plus jeunes vont changer
allure et bordures sept ans à
l'ambassade s'étend sur 30 ans 30 mètres
carrés à l'ambassade d'équateur et à la
hauteur avec son chat avec sa minceur
loin et le chant c'est important j'adore
les chambres on va me faire une émission
bientôt sur les chats je suis sûr alors
au label à tout le monde a du cisme
allemande pour ça c'est l'image la
semaine à la salle signal du satellite
qui nous indique que tout va s'arrêter
dans le commencement du très prolongée
alors sur ce trait mercier notre note
régis aujourd'hui marc andré deschamps
et benoît durand magnifique travail
encore une fois et pier dutil qui je
sais pas trop ce qu'il fait mais il est
pas beau ça marie claude simard merci
vraiment démarqué au fantastique
quant à lui bien et puis allez bientôt
ben je vois au coin de la rue je ne veux
pas aller chantal passé de souligner on
va inverser sa lutte non